justement il ya quand même des choses
qui vont bien tout de même la société
alstom et la sncf grâce au tgv
remportent des succès à l'étranger
notamment récemment en espagne
et puis l'inauguration cette semaine du
tgv atlantique qui non seulement va très
très vite
mais qui est également une magnifique
machine jacques violet jean cordier deux
générations deux tgv qui se croisent
huit ans les séparent
le nouveau argent et bleue continue
entre paris et lyon les essais les
dernières mises au point en huit ans
beaucoup de changement et d'amélioration
le profil plus pointu et un carénage
plus aérodynamique les moteurs ils sont
synchrones c'est à dire à la fois plus
légers et plus puissant il utilise du
courant triphasé au lieu du continu pour
une masse comparable au tgv sud-est
l'atlantique à une puissance double la
suspension point noir du grand frère a
été considérablement améliorée
aujourd'hui une suspension pneumatique
de l'air comprimé et des normes
amortisseurs donne une meilleure assise
plus aucune vibration la vitesse c'est
aussi le freinage quatre doubles disques
en acier non ventilées des freins
surpuissant l'équivalent d'un abs pour
les voitures toutes ces améliorations
techniques dû à l'expérience donne à 300
kilomètres heure la vitesse commerciale
de ce nouveau train le confort d'une
voiture corail classique à 160 dans la
cabine l'électronique et l'informatique
assiste le mécanicien contrôler la
vitesse et surveille l'état de marche de
la ram en temps réel
ah bon une capacité plus importante
485 passagers par rame au lieu de 386
sur le sud-est l'intérieur des voitures
a également été très largement revu on a
diversifié les espaces petit salon en
première compartiment pour les familles
les groupes espace pour enfants
enfin une voiture complètement consacré
aux barres et à la restauration et 2
publiphones à 40 pour la sncf
une augmentation importante de trafic
vers l'ouest ce train va prendre comme
sur lyon beaucoup de passagers à l'avion
et la voiture mais également des
passagers nouveau nous pensons que sur
le tgv atlantique comme sur le tgv sud
est la présence d'un nouveau moyen de
transport performant va créer de
nouveaux besoins de transport et que
nous aurons environ 40% d'induction de
pratique du simplement à l'existence de
ce nouveau mode en région parisienne on
termine les travaux sur la ligne
nouvelle
on pose la caténaire la ligne électrique
et l'on achèvent les finitions dans les
tunnels
à partir du mois de septembre prochain
paris le mans en une heure
paris rennes ou nantes 2 heures le tgv
nouveau est arrivé